I mean the best email resistant Kenya my
goal is to be the best female eclipse'
okay necessary is my data and we are
best friends
[Music]
My name is Matthew Bureau like doing 50
names your passion and a vehicle they
also do weightlifting my elder brother
was Ali Krista and there is no company
into the gym so in 1999 there were no
women resistance so they were asking the
ladies to come and join and that's how I
dreamed and we never look fast I said
with lifting allows 11 years old I used
to go in my mouth to the gym whenever
she was training at the gym we do many
exercises and have cost the deadlift
bench presses shoulder press to do back
extensions when it comes to doing those
conditioning exercises it is laughs I
surrender my defeat ah ha ha I've
competed in four Commonwealth Games for
all Africans for African Championships
and in one Olympic Games
Natasha one day is going to be where I
am
natasha is a strong lady
I can say that that's why I even thought
that I should introduce him to the spot
and motivate her and push her to be even
better than me and become the top Vista
in Kenya what makes me part of my mom is
that she stands out from the rest and
she's a strong woman I wanted to be a
resolution because mother she has had me
Olins
and she told me from the first day that
I can make it a hand do it
[Music]